Good morning, I greet you, Andrés González,
as some of the most
outstanding news of the day,
school district officials are investigating a
fight between multiple students that
broke out Monday at Green Valley High School
after reports and rumors on
social media that it had been
reported.  a shooting on campus
high school administrators
were forced to notify
parents and clarify that it was a
violent fight and that they managed to control it
and classes resumed at a normal time
and only weeks after the start of the
school year the district
the cis is still short staffed and it says it needs
school bus drivers
there are currently 15 percent
vacancies for drivers and the shortage is
causing a domino effect with delays and
errors on routes the district is
offering a wage of $16 an
hour  For people interested in
applying for a job
and if you need to renew your passport
soon  Just don't wait because there is a
high delay in the procedures The
state department that issues
passports says that it has seen
a backlog since the
pandemic began and that some applicants have
had to wait up to five months
to renew their passports while
those  who pay extra to
speed up the process have had to
wait at least three months are asked
to wait for their
passport to expire and request a new one.
It should also be noted that most
airlines waive the fees for
changes to flights if you do not receive  your
passport on time
and if you need help paying rent
and you live in the city las vegas
a new assistance program is now open
the city has 13 million dollars
in budget to help
people who need help this due
to the pandemic to  get more details
call 70 22 29 59 35 they are
open Monday to Friday from 7 and 35 pm we have
more information in our  stra page of
news now dotcom diagonal in Spanish
and if you want to get the coitus vaccine you
can do it in various places
around the valley today there is a
pop-up clinic in the dolphin room located on
the second floor of the rings it
works from 8 in the morning  until
noon and in the circus and a clinic
from 3 to 5 both are
open to people from 12 years old
you can find a complete list of
clinics in the news now dotcom
diagonal in Spanish
and let's see what the weather forecast brings us
today will be another hot day with
a maximum of 103 degrees
the air quality alert remains until
wednesday and we continue in the triple
digits with an increase for next
week so take care of the heat that is
all the information for today i inform you of
andrés gonzález  and this was about
the news now in Spanish
[Music]